Derrick Rose I've been watching you for
a long time you're the three-eyed bird
no that's Larry what is this place where
are we
North Carolina we were here long before
the Bobcats I seek your wisdom so that I
may be a great ball like you once where
I can teach you how to fly like an eagle
you must trust your teammates learn from
your failures and whatever you do don't
try baseball thank you I'm so grateful I
kneel before you no no no no not the
knees are you lonely chessboard were you
bored a lot too in the NBA no I was a
starter are you ashamed of me Father
when you were drafted hopes for you were
high but you start quickly plummeted
everyone advised me not to make the
trade and let you live out your short
career in New Orleans I told them all to
go to hell
because you did not belong cross the
world with the bloody pelicans you are
the former first-team all-acc McDonald's
all-american Naismith prep Player of the
Year and you are my son
does this mean I get to start next year
let's not get crazy and Kyle Lowry cos
Brutus six with all his bitter woes and
so he choked and so he choked the Lord
of Tehran
yeah play play the tale of the big free
happy sorry Championships won in 2008 it
was sick of it that team was nothing
without me
I was off in legend in Boston yeah ma a
legend but I like that song you should
shut you off and hold your ginger head
so I could piss in any gutter and score
more points than fire for you I wouldn't
stand a chance none of us would I
wouldn't go that far
who the hell was that it's no wonder
they kicked you out of Dallas there's a
special place for lonely trash talkers
like yourself and like this game and
where the hell do you suppose that is
Los Angeles